I've become very very interested in the
idea of playing in games that have no
finish lines right
some games have finish line's right
baseball football right
getting apart is the finish line you
audition there's a beginning middle and
end
whose rehearsal and practice there's
showing up for the audition and you
either win or you lose and then it's
over it's over right that is finite but
one's career is infinite there's there's
no end it's like our lives are finite
but life is infinite people come and
people go but life continues right
theater actors come in actors go but
theater continues it's infinite you
don't win theater you win a part but
what happens once you get the part the
finite game is over now you enter the
infinite game you have to be able to
convert right and the reason this is
important and I've seen this
unfortunately so many times from a young
age all you wanted to do was get to
Broadway and then you get to Broadway
and then what you've devoted your entire
life to one finite goal and when you get
there the immediate response is
depression because I spent 15 years of
my life for this one thing and I got it
and now I don't know what to do next
like what a get to Broadway again
doesn't have the same ambition
it doesn't have the same passion you
know that you've devoted your from you
know you're from Fargo North Dakota and
that's all you wanted to do is get out
of Fargo and make it to Broadway and you
made it right it doesn't have the same
kind of passion and this is because
these are finite goals there's a lot of
studies that have been done with
athletes who have finite goals to become
the greatest X in the world right so
Andre Agassi was one of these one of
these athletes he wanted to become the
greatest tennis player that ever lived
guess what everyone in his life he would
he would view them through how do you
help me get to that everything was how
does this help me get to that everything
was a transaction to how do you help me
move to there and then you know what
happens he achieved it he became the
greatest tennis player in the world and
you know what happened immediately after
Depression Michael Phelps set out to
become the most medaled Olympian in
history you know what he achieved it you
know what happened immediately after
depression they spend their whole life
working for one goal though most will
never get it the few that do don't know
what to do next because their goals were
finite their goals were finite right and
so there are finite components to your
career but your career should be
infinite so yes of course you have to
win the finite game you have to get the
part but immediately when you get the
part now you convert to infinite
[Music]